>> I GAVE HIM A GUN, I GAVE HIM
A BADGE.
I GAVE HIM THE TRAINING.
IF HE DIDN’T HAVE THE HEART TO
GO IN THAT’S NOT MY
RESPONSIBILITY.
>> LISA: THAT WAS EMBATTLED
BROWARD COUNTY SHERIFF ISRAEL
JUST TWO WEEKS AFTER THE
SHOOTING AT PARKLAND HIGH
SCHOOL, REFUSING TO TAKE ANY
RESPONSIBILITY IN THE BREAKDOWN
THAT COULD HAVE ULTIMATELY SAVED
LIVES.
DESPITE CALLS FOR RESIGNATION
INCLUDING GOVERNOR RICK SCOTT,
SHERIFF ISRAEL IS STILL ON THE
JOB.
NOW, ONE OF FLORIDA’S BIGGEST
NEWSPAPERS ADMITS THAT IT MADE A
MISTAKE AND SAYS THE SHERIFF
NEEDS TO GO.
THE SUN SENTINEL EDITORIAL
WRITING, "THE SHERIFF FAILS TO
ACCEPT RESPONSIBILITY FOR THINGS
THAT HAVE GONE WRONG INSTEAD
SUGGESTING THAT THINGS COULDN’T
HAVE BEEN BETTER.
IF HE FAILS TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
MISTAKES WERE MADE NOT ONLY BY
INDIVIDUALS BUT BY HIS COMMAND,
HOW CAN WE EXPECT A BETTER
OUTCOME NEXT TIME?"
JONATHAN HUNT IS LIVE IN OUR
WEST COAST NEWSROOM WITH THE
STORY.
JONATHAN?
JONATHAN: LISA, SCOTT ISRAEL HAS
BEEN FIGHTING FOR HIS JOB EVER
SINCE THE FEBRUARY MASS SHOOTING
OF MAJORY STONEMAN DOUGLAS HIGH
SCHOOL.
THE BIGGEST ISSUE BEYOND HIS
SELF-PRAISE, THE WITNESS
STATEMENTS THAT HIGHLIGHTED THE
CONTRAST BETWEEN BROWARD
SHERIFF’S DEPUTY’S ACTIONS AS
THE SHOOTING UNFOLDED AND THOSE
OF CORAL SPRINGS POLICE
OFFICERS.
A STATE APPOINTED SAFETY
COMMISSION SAID SHERIFF’S
DEPUTIES, SOME OF THEM AT LEAST,
APPEARED TO TAKE THEIR TIME
39-ING ON VESTS WHEN THEY
ARRIVED AT THE SCHOOL AND TOOK
COVER BEHIND THEIR VEHICLES
RATHER THAN IMMEDIATELY ENTERING
THE SCHOOL TO CONFRONT THE
SHOOTER.
POLICE OFFICERS ACCORDING TO THE
COMMISSION WERE FAR MORE
PROACTIVE.
THE COMMISSION FOUND THAT EIGHT
SHERIFF’S DEPUTIES HEARD
GUNFIRE, BUT DID NOT IMMEDIATELY
ENTER THE BUILDING.
ONE OF THOSE WITH THE SCHOOL
RESOURCE OFFICER DEPUTY SCOTT
PETERSON.
HE, OF COURSE, WAS SEEN ON VIDEO
APPEARING TO HIDE BEHIND A WALL.
HE WAS SUSPENDED AT THE TIME,
PENDING AN INVESTIGATION, AND
LATER RESIGNED.
IN A LETTER TO THE SAFETY
COMMISSION ON WEDNESDAY, SHERIFF
ISRAEL HIGHLIGHTED POLICY
CHANGES INSTIGATED SINCE THE
SHOOTING, BUT AGAIN DEFENDED HIS
DEPARTMENT’S POLICIES AT THE
TIME OF THE SHOOTING, SAYING "IT
IS THE STRONG BELIEF OF THIS
SHERIFF THAT NO POLICIES, NO
WORDS WOULD HAVE LED TO DEPUTY
PETERSON GOING INTO THAT
BUILDING."
NOW THE INFLUENTIAL SUN SENTINEL
NEWSPAPER WHICH INITIALLY
DEFENDED THE SHERIFF IS CALLING
FOR HIS REMOVAL FROM OFFICE.
SOMETHING PARENTS OF SOME OF
THOSE WHO DIED THAT FEBRUARY DAY
HAVE LONG DEMANDED.
NOW, INCOMING REPUBLICAN
GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS, WHO TAKES
OFFICE ON JANUARY 8, COULD
SUSPEND SHERIFF ISRAEL ONCE THE
SAFETY COMMISSION REPORT IS
FORMALLY PUBLISHED.
THE SHERIFF TOLD THE MIAMI
HAROLD THIS WEEK HE HAS "NO
PLANS TO RESIGN."
LISA?
>> LISA: THANK YOU, JONATHAN.
JOINING ME NOW IS A MAN WHO HAS
BEEN CALLING FOR SHERIFF
ISRAEL’S RESIGNATION FROM THE
BEGINNING.
JEFF BELL, PRESIDENT OF THE
BROWARD SHERIFF’S OFFICE
DEPUTY’S ASSOCIATION.
JEFF, THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH
US, SIR.
>> GOOD EVENING.
>>.
>> LISA: I WANT TO TALK TO YOU
ABOUT THE SHIFT BY THE SUN
SENTINEL.
WHY IS THAT IMPORTANT?
>> THAT IS HUGE DOWN HERE IN
SOUTH FLORIDA.
THE SUN SENTINEL HAS ALWAYS BEEN
KNOWN AS A LEFT LEANING LIBERAL
INSPECT WHO HAS DEFENDED THE
SHERIFF AT ALL COSTS.
ALMOST, A ROMANTIC RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE SHERIFF’S OFFICE OVER
THEM TO COME OUT AND ADMIT THEY
THE PAST COUPLE OF YEARS SO FOR
MADE A MISTAKE IS HUGE.
IF YOU REMEMBER BACK IN APRIL OF
THIS YEAR 85% OF OUR MEMBERSHIP
THIS YEAR 85% OF OUR MEMBERSHIP VOTED THAT WE HAD NO CONFIDENCE
VOTED THAT WE HAD NO CONFIDENCE
IN THE SHERIFF AND CALLED FOR
HIS REMOVAL.
THAT ACTION DREW SHARP CRITICISM
FROM THE SUN SENTINEL AND THEY
WROTE A TWO-PAGE ARTICLE AGAINST
THE UNION SAYING WE WERE
OVERREACTING AND TRYING TO
EXTORT THE SHERIFF FOR A BETTER
CONTRACT OVER THE PARKLAND
MASSACRE, WHICH WAS THE
FARTHERMOST FROM THE TRUTH.
SOMEBODY IN THE LAST EIGHT
MONTHS AT THE SUN SENTINEL
FINALLY FOUND THE COURAGE AND
GREW A BACKBONE AND UNLEASHED
THEIR INVESTIGATIVE REPORTER TO
GO OUT AND FIND THE TRUTH.
EIGHT MONTHS LATER AFTER OUR NO
VOTE OF CONFIDENCE FOR SCOTT
ISRAEL THE SUN SENTINEL, LARGEST
SUPPORTER OF SHERIFF ISRAEL HAS
FINALLY REACHED THE SAME
CONCLUSION, THAT THIS UNION AND
THE MEN AND WOMEN OF THE BROWARD
SHERIFF’S OFFICE REACHED EIGHT
MONTHS EARLIER, WHICH IS SHERIFF
ISRAEL NEEDS TO BE REMOVED FROM
THE BROWARD SHERIFF’S OFFICE
IMMEDIATELY.
>> LISA: SIR WHAT GOES THROUGH
YOUR MIND WHEN YOU HEAR THAT
PATTERSON DID NOT GO IN, THAT
THESE OTHER DEPUTIES TOOK THEIR
TIME PUTTING ON THEIR VESTS AND
TIME PUTTING ON THEIR VESTS AND DID NOT GO IN WHAT GOES THROUGH
DID NOT GO IN WHAT GOES THROUGH
YOUR MIND?
>> YOU FEEL DISAPPOINTED THAT WE
DIDN’T MAKE THE RIGHT DECISIONS
THAT DAY.
BUT OUTSIDE OF THE 4R5U6
COMMUNITY YOU CAN UNDERSTAND THE
ANGER FROM THE COMMUNITY.
WITHIN OUR OWN DEPARTMENT, WE
UNDERSTAND WHY FAILURES AT THIS
LEVEL TOOK PLACE ON THIS DAY.
WHEN YOU HAVE A SHERIFF WHO, ON
NOVEMBER 4, 2013, INTERVENED
HIMSELF INTO OUR ACTIVE SHOOTER
POLICY, AND TOOK OUT THE WORD
"WILL RESPOND" AND REPLACED IT
HIMSELF WITH "MAY RESPOND," IT
CAUSES A DISCONCERN, OF WHAT
ACTION THEY SHOULD TAKE AND WHEN
HE PUBLICLY ANNOUNCE THAT IS
WE’RE NO LONGER A LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY, AND WE’RE NO
A COMMUNITY-BASED LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY, AND WE’LL
HELP OUT THE COMMUNITY RATHER
THAN 9:00 TO FIGHT CRIME IN
BROWARD COUNTY WE’RE TAKING THE
WRONG APPROACH AND STRIPPING THE
MONEY AWAY FROM OUR TRAINING
BUDGET SO WE SPEND MORE TIME IN
CLASSROOMS LEARNING ABOUT
POLITENESS AND POLICING AND WE
ONLY SPEND FOUR HOURS A YEAR,
CAN YOU BELIEVE THAT FOUR HOURS
A YEAR PRACTICING WITH OUR GUNS
ON A GUN RANGE THAT WE LEASE
FROM THE COUNTY, THE NATION’S
LARGEST FULLY ACCREDITED
SHERIFF’S OFFICE, WHICH IS THE
BROWARD SHERIFF’S OFFICE DOES
NOT EVEN HAVE THEIR OWN GUN
RANGE OR TRAINING FACILITY TO
PRACTICE FOR THESE EVENTS, AND I
PUT THE FULL BLAME ON SHERIFF
SCOTT ISRAEL FOR HIS
INTERVENTION INTO THESE POLICIES
AND FOR FAILURE TO DEMAND FROM
THE BROWARD COUNTY COMMISSION A
PROPER TRAINING FACILITY SO WE
CAN BETTER PREPARE FOR THE NEXT
INCIDENT WHICH IS JUST WAITING
FOR US AROUND THE CORNER.
>> LISA: SIR WHAT DO YOU KNOW
ABOUT THE COMMISSION REPORT?
ANY KEY FINDINGS THAT VIEWERS AT
HOME NEED TO KNOW ABOUT?
>> WELL THAT WILL BE MADE PUBLIC
ON JANUARY 1.
WE’VE MADE RECOMMENDATIONS,
GOVERNOR-ELECT RON DeSANTIS THAT
WE NEED TO TAKE BETTER COURSES
OF ACTIONS WITH OUR JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM HERE IN THE STATE
OF FLORIDA.
I CAN TELL YOU THIS.
ON AGAIN 14, 2018, NIKOLAS CRUZ
AND NIKOLAS CRUZ ONLY WENT INTO
THE SCHOOL AND PULLED THAT
TRIGGER WHICH COST 17 PEOPLE
THEIR LIVES BUT THE FAILED
PROGRAMS SUCH AS THE PROMISE
PROGRAM AND THE LACK OF
TRAINING, AND THE POLICIES THAT
THIS SHERIFF HASIATED WITHIN
BROWARD COUNTY, DID NOT CREATE
NIKOLAS CRUZ BUT IT CERTAINLY
CREATED AN ENVIRONMENT WHICH
ALLOWED SOMEBODY LIKE NIKOLAS
CRUZ TO FLOURISH IN, AND WE’RE
SEEING THE RESULTS OF THE POOR
POLICIES AND THE PROMISE PROGRAM
TAKING EFFECT WHERE KIDS TODAY
ARE NO LONGER HELD RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE ACTIONS THAT THEY TAKE
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY.
>> LISA: THESE FAMILIES
CERTAINLY DESERVE ACCOUNTABILITY
AND ONE OF THE ISSUES AND
FRUSTRATION FOR SO MANY
AMERICANS IS THE FACT THAT
SHERIFF ISRAEL REFUSES,
CONTINUOUSLY REFUSES TO TAKE ANY
RESPONSIBILITY AND IT REALLY
DOES START AT THE TOP, AS YOU
LAID OUT.
HOW DOES IT MAKE YOU FEEL WHEN
YOU HEAR SHERIFF ISRAEL JUST
REFUSE TO TAKE ANY
RESPONSIBILITY FOR HIS ACTIONS
OR HIS FAILED LEADERSHIP?
>> THERE IS ONE WORD TO DESCRIBE
THE SHERIFF.
NARCISSISTIC.
THIS SHERIFF BELIEVES THAT
NOTHING CAN BE HIS FAULT AND
EVERYTHING HE DOES IS PURELY FOR
POLITICAL GAIN.
THIS MAN IS APPOINTED LEADERSHIP
WITHIN THE BROWARD COUNTY
SHERIFF’S OFFICE THAT’S
INCOMPETENCE AT BEST.
HIS CRONY THAT IS 450EZ BROUGHT
INTO THIS RAGTCY, A PERFECT
EXAMPLE, JORDAN, CAPTAIN OF PARK
LAND ON THE DAY OF THE MASSACRE.
WHAT WERE HER QUALIFICATIONS?
THAT SHE WAS A DIVERSITY PICK
FROM SHERIFF ISRAEL?
OR THAT SHE WAS COMPETENT, SHE
WASRA GREAT LEADER?
NO, SHE WAS NOT.
AND THAT WAS PROVEN BECAUSE SHE
WAS OVERWHELMED WITHIN THE VERY
FIRST MINUTE OF THE SHOOTING.
THAT CAPTAIN WOULD HAVE BEEN
OVERWHELMED WITH A SIMPLE
TRAFFIC STOP AND THAT WAS THE
SHERIFF’S NUMBER ONE PICK TO GO
INTO PARKLAND AS THE CAPTAIN IN
THAT DISTRICT.
>> LISA: DO YOU EXPECT THE
INCOMING GOVERNOR,
GOVERNOR-ELECT DE SAPTIS TO TAKE
ACTION REGARDING ISRAEL?
>> I’VE BEEN HOPING FOR THE PAST
10 MOTION THAT GOVERNOR SCOTT
WOULD TAKE ACTION.
HE’S FAILED TO DO SO.
IT’S NOT AN EASY DECISION BUT
IT’S THE RIGHT DECISION.
I HAVE MADE MY OPINIONS VERY
CLEAR TO GOVERNOR-ELECT RON
DeSANTIS.
HE KNOWS MY OPINIONS ON THE
SHERIFF AND HE KNOWS WHAT NEEDS
TO BE DONE TO FIX BROWARD
COUNTY, NOT JUST WITHIN THE
SHERIFF’S DEPARTMENT BUT THERE
ARE OTHER AREAS THAT NEED TO BE
FIXED, SO HOPEFULLY, WITH THE
REPORT THAT COMES OUT ON JANUARY
1, AND THEN WHAT’S EXPECTED TO
BE THE FDLE REPORT SHORTLY AFTER